may giuseppem pants is having a hard
time these days is his village being
forcibly ruled by the Spanish government
or is the community part of the Free
Republic of Catalonia the residents of
Santa Paul a mountain village in rural
Catalonia want to know almost everyone
here voted in favor of Independence in
the controversial referendum and they
haven't changed their position I would
like for the new Catalan Republic to be
socially and politically sound a
republic established by its citizens the
regular people from the ground up it's
been a long time since the Spanish flag
has flown above the town hall in Santa
Paul the local council still considers
ousted regional leader Carlos put Jamal
their head of government it doesn't
matter if he's abroad or appearing
before a Spanish Court proponents of
Independence continue to adhere to
different laws in 900 towns in Catalonia
more than 700 mayors are refusing to
comply with Spanish government orders we
will face the consequences
I could be removed from office but we've
been fighting for independence for many
years so we're not suddenly going to
start following orders from Madrid now
on October 27th the Catalan Parliament
declared independence
combined celebrated the historic
decision with hundreds of other mayors
in the parliament building in Barcelona
but no country in the world recognizes
the Republic of Catalonia and the
Spanish government is imposing its
authority on the region it seems that
since the order was given catalan
separatists have been living in a
parallel reality we've waited many many
years for this moment one of the reasons
I went into politics was to do something
for my municipality but I also did it to
establish a new republic and achieve
independence for Catalonia back in Santa
Paula
there's agriculture and tourism here but
no large companies that could decide to
relocate elsewhere the local carpenter
shop has seen better days but that
doesn't mean salvador sarah has letting
himself be intimidated by threats of
trade barriers he says Spain is just a
liability first of all there's the
corruption in Spain and second people in
the South in Andalusia and Extremadura
living off our tax payments in the
afternoon there's just one topic of
conversation in the village prob locals
are following the ousted president every
move on television they say the struggle
for power is only just beginning they
can do whatever they want it might take
some time but Madrid will lose in the
end
centre power is taking on the world the
going could get tough but as the
villagers say if things get really bad
they still have their fortress